cette vidéo est une collaboration avec
la chaîne du cnrs zeste de science est
ce que vous voyez s'écouler c'est ce
qu'on appelle les larmes du vin ou le
même les jambes du vin c'est un film de
liquide donc du vin qui est restée
accrochée sur le vert après qu'on l'ait
fait tournoyer ce qui est assez logique
mais ce qui serait encore plus logique
en fait c'est que cette fine couche de
vingt finissent par s'évaporer ou même
pas retomber dans le verbe comme c'est
le cas pour un verre d'eau par exemple
or avec le vin les larmes ne
disparaissent pas parce que le vin
remonte sur les parois du verre vous
avez bien entendu il remonte il parle en
bas et il remonte dans le sens inverse
diop à l'épinard aujourd'hui je bouge du
vent un jeu manque de bouteilles de
beaujolais pour 6 2
[Musique]
évidemment marié en train de passer avec
de l'eau mais pas directement repas
c'est quand même
geagea vinasse gros rouge qui tâche on
sait que l'on peut produire d'excellents
veulent à ses bénéfices sont de faibles
et au pire carrément il existe alors je
n'ai pas découvert que le vin monter sur
les parois du verre comme vous pourriez
l'imaginer je pense que vous imaginez
que c'était moi même en buvant du vin
non parce que pour la simple et bonne
raison que je ne bois pas d'alcool je
n'aime pas ça donc s'il vous plaît ne
soyez pas choqués par ma bouteille de
vin qu'il ya un bouchon en plastique est
une marque bizarre rose bonbon
j'ai pris le premier que j'ai trouvé de
toute façon je vais pas le boire j'ai
découvert en réalité que les larmes
monter sur le vert en allant dans le
laboratoire où josé bic au travail et
c'est avec lui que j'avais fait la vidéo
sur les poils qui colle dans le
téléphone alors dit comme ça c'est sûr
que c'est bizarre vous vous cirque et
pouvoir et à la fin de notre rencontre
pour cette vidéo il m'avait dit au fait
est-ce que tu connais ça et voici la
démonstration qu'ils m'avaient fait
[Musique]
c'est pas super un joli franchement et
on peut même en prendre une photo et
cette jolie démonstration va nous
permettre de comprendre pourquoi les
larmes du 20 grammes sur le vert mais
avec une expérience un peu plus joli
le grand point commun entre ça et le vin
c'est l'alcool dans ma boîte de pétri
j'ai un bain d'huile est ce que j'ajoute
avec ma pipe est c'est une goutte d'un
mélange d'eau et d'alcool avec du
colorant pour qu'on puisse le voir
et pour comprendre à quel point c'est
vraiment l'alcool qui est la clé on va
l'enlever de l'équation
si je verse uniquement un goutte d'eau
sur lui vous savez déjà ce qui se passe
puisque c'est la saison des vinaigrettes
mélo reste toute recroquevillée sur
elle-même pour limiter au maximum le
contact avec lui l'huile et l'ol sont
pas très copines qu'aucune si au
contraire on met de l'alcool pur du
moins aussi pure que ce que je peux m'en
fournir à la pharmacie notre gouttes
s'étale énormément à la surface l'alcool
a beaucoup d'affinités avec lui alors il
prend toute la place disponible
parenthèse vous savez qu'on utilise
souvent cette expression de dire que les
liquides sem ou ne sais même pas ce qui
n'est pas hyper cohérent pour des
liquides puisque jusqu'à preuve du
contraire ils n'ont pas de sentiment en
fait quand on dit que les liquides cm ou
non on parle de leur capacité à se
mélanger et donc à créer des liaisons
chimiques entre eux entre les deux
liquides pour accrocher les molécules de
l'ain aux molécules de l'autre camp des
molécules sem
en fait ça veut dire qu'elles sont
capables soin de créer beaucoup de
liaison soit de créer des liaisons
particulièrement forte
soit les entre l'eau et l'huile ça
marche pas elle s'aime pas mais avec
l'alcool ça marche
elles sont super copine et retenez ça
parce que ça va être important pour la
suite l'alcool c'est al lowe se met en
boule se rétracte
fin de la parenthèse maintenant si on
met un mélange d'eau et d'alcool sur
l'huile on se retrouve avec un
comportement intermédiaire dynamique
vraiment intéressant et là j'espère que
vous voyez l'analogie avec notre verre
de vin l'eau et l'alcool correspondent
aux vins et la couche d'huile correspond
robert gamez gouttes tombent
il ya un gros volume du mélange coloré
qui se dépose et qui prend sa place sur
le deed sur deux sur lui comme il ya de
l'alcool de dans le mélange s'étale
depuis le centre de la route vers
l'extérieur et forcément la partie est
allée est plus fine que là où la boot a
été déposée il ya beaucoup plus de
volume mais comme l'alcool c'est quelque
chose de très volatile d'ailleurs en son
honneur
en tout cas beaucoup plus que l'eau ne
s'évapore ça veut dire que les endroits
où la couche était la plus fine mais
alors plus du tout d'alcool alors qu'il
en reste encore au centre de la goutte
là où il y avait beaucoup plus de
victimes et ça agit comme réservoir
alcool on a donc une quantité d'alcool
variable entre le centre et les bords
sauf que tintin tintin
comme c'était l'alcool qui permettait
l'étalement mais qui a plus d'alcool au
bout ça veut dire qu'il ne reste plus
que de l'eau donc la boue t'arrêtes de
s'étaler mais pire que ça elle voudrait
même se rétracter puisqu'il ya plus que
de l'eau vous avez dit que ça allait
être important que l'eau se rétracte et
l'alcool s'étale à l'extérieur il ya
plus d'alcool n'est plus que de l'eau
donc ça veut se rétracter sauf que
tintin beats vous le voyez la goutte ne
se rétracte pas tant que ça hein
en tout cas pas tout de suite c'est
parce que le centre de la goutte
alimente sans arrêt la périphérie en
alcool il ya donc un courant du mélange
coloré du centre à la périphérie
je répète parce que c'est important il
ya un courant du centre vers les bords
d'un courant donc un déplacement de
liquide qui n'est pas créée par un
moteur ni par une différence de hauteur
mais par la chimie de la chose connue
sous le nom de l'effet marangoni alors
l'effet marangoni c'est un courant d'eau
liquide qui a vu lorsqu'on a un gradient
de tension de surface une variation de
tension de surface à un endroit on a une
surface qui tire fort et à un autre
endroit on a une surface qui étions
moins forts
ce déséquilibre de force entraîne un
mouvement de la zone de faible tension
surface à la zone 2 haute tension de
surface du centre de la goutte aux
extrémités pour moi le plus dur à
comprendre ça a été l'action de tirer
comment est-ce que ça tire et j'ai adoré
l'expérience que j'ai vu sur la chaîne
youtube de unisciel qui a vraiment
débloqué ma compréhension
ici vous avez une bulle de savon de
chaque côté de la tige et on éclate une
seule des deux bulles comme la tige est
libre de bouger elle est tirée par la
bulle qui reste donc c'est vraiment une
tension réelle qui a dans la surface
elle tire
moi personnellement j'aime bien imaginer
les molécules de la surface comme si
elle se tenait par la main pour
représenter les liaisons inter
moléculaire et chacune des molécules
tire aussi fort à droite qu'à gauche
alors ça marche très bien quand toutes
les molécules tire tout de la même façon
mais si on a de l'eau d'un côté qui tire
très fort et de l'alcool de l'autre qui
tirent moins fort ben c'est comme ça que
le courant de marée honey secret
sauf que tam tam tam terre du coup non
seulement il ya un courant mais il
s'auto entretient aussi le mélange aux
alcools et
et donc vers les bords mais l'alcool une
fois arrivé sur les bords il s'évapore à
nouveau ne laissa alors la place qu'à
l'eau qui tirent encore sur le centre
pour aller créer un courant qui ramène
du mélange coloré etc etc n'ont qu'un
mouvement qui s'entretient jusqu'à ce
que tout l'alcool soit évaporée et c'est
ce même phénomène qui entretient les
larmes du vin
ok donc j'ai bien conscience que là ce
que vous êtes en train de voir ce sont
des gouttes qui tombent et c'est vrai
d'ailleurs attendre à d'ailleurs en
reparler dans une minute mais ce que ça
implique c'est que pour avoir de
l'alcool qui tombe dans le vert il a
d'abord fallu en emmener vers le haut et
ceux dont je parle là tout de suite
c'est de ça c'est de cette ascension
d'alcool de l'intérieur du verre
jusqu'au bord du verbe
malheureusement on ne le voit pas mais
ya bien du liquide qui monte sinon il
n'y en aurait pas qu'ils redescendraient
il ya juste un film de 20 sur les parois
qui tellement fin que l'alcool s'évapore
ne laissant alors plus que look est dans
le vin parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'eau en
vain celle ci a une tension de surface
tellement forte qu'elle tire sur le vin
qui est dans le vert et le fait monter
sur les parois ces forces sont donc plus
forte que la gravité et remonte sur les
parois du moins jusqu'à un certain point
jusqu'à ce bourg les convois ici dans le
vert du vin est ici dans l'expérience le
bourrelet vient du fait qu'on a ce
combat entre deux phénomènes une envie
de se rétracter parce qu'il n'ya que de
l'eau sur les bords mais l'impossibilité
de le faire parce qu'il ya un courant
permanent qui vient du centre et qui
amène toujours de l'alcool et donc sa
forme un beau relais sauf que pas de tam
tam tam cette fois ci je pense que
c'était déjà trop de le faire trois fois
un bourrelet liquide s'est pas stable il
finit par se décomposer dans un chapelet
de gouttelettes comme un filet d'eau qui
s'écoule d'un robinet ou bien comme les
gouttelettes de vin qui coule sur le
vert vous aurez donc compris que ce
mouvement auto entretenue des larmes du
vin est donc avant tout créer par le
taux d'alcool du vin l'effet marangoni
et la clé de cette expérience et il ya
un autre endroit où vous pouvez voir cet
effet et c'est au petit déjeuner du mois
si vous
avait un petit déjeuner très français
qui consiste en des tartines beurrées et
si vous les tremper dans le café ou le
thé vous aurez une manifestation de plus
de l'effet marangoni mais je vous
détaille pas plus parce que je veux vous
renvoyer vers la vidéo de zeste de
sciences qui en parle
pour vous donner un peu l'histoire de
cette jolie expérience elle a été
inventée par le professeur gustavo
gutiérrez j'espère je prononce bien
qu'il utilisait pour titiller la
curiosité des élèves dans les écoles de
caracas au venezuela et alors qu'il
était de passage à paris il avait aussi
fait sa démonstration au laboratoire où
josé toute son équipe travaillent et ils
avaient eux-mêmes étaient fascinés par
cette danse des petites gouttelettes et
cette démonstration pour les enfants a
donc donné lieu à de nombreuses heures
de réflexion à toute l'équipe et à la
publication d'articles scientifiques et
aussi une superbe vidéo
j'en profite pour remercier josé pour
ces recherches qui sont très visuel ce
qui est drôlement pratique pour de la
vidéo et pour prendre le temps de les
communiquer et même de vérifier mes
scripts enfant ou adulte je vous invite
alors à reproduire à l'expérience
elle est tellement simple affaire que
vous avez aucune excuse posté une photo
de votre oeuvre sur les réseaux sociaux
en meute à gand et avec le hashtag art
alcoolique
si cette expérience vous a fasciné pour
des raisons plus artistique que
scientifique je vous invite aussi à
aller découvrir l'art du sou mina gâchis
qui se basent exactement sur ces
principes des faits marangoni pour en
faire vraiment des oeuvres d'art est
allé voir la vidéo de zeste de sciences
et nous on se retrouve pas tout de suite
je vais ralentir cet été pas parce que
je prends énormément de vacances mais
simplement pour essayer de prendre de
l'avancé sur les prochaines vidéos et
vous offrir un contenu de qualité et
original à la rentrée je vous souhaite
un bel été et à bientôt